the kids are back in school and they're
starting to get back into their routines
and beauty and lifestyle advisor Don
McCarthy is here with some products that
will surely make back to school life
easier welcome back Dawn so good to see
you good to see you too so first up I'm
going to start out with diaper.com and I
know it's been a while since you've had
to use a diaper bag yeah it has but your
kids are getting older but one thing
that you always need are wipes and I
love these wipes from diaper whether you
have a kid or don't have a kid this is
all about keeping your hands clean and
any surface is clean you can't go wrong
especially in this day and age where
we're all about trying to keep things
clean having the baby wipes yes and what
I love about these they're 99 water
they're unscented so you don't have to
worry about anything diaper is all about
good for baby products good for you good
for kids and most important good for the
planet so like this diaper bag that's
kind of can fill everything this is
great for guys it's really General
neutral in color these are just going to
kind of keep our hands nice and not dry
them out that's what I like I there's no
scent and yeah everything just feels
kind of hydrated exactly yeah and
they've got a B Corp status so you know
when you're getting this product from
diaper you're getting something that's
really good and they have amazing
obviously diapers as well oh I love that
okay let's talk shoes I I saw these I'm
like these are so adorable tell me about
it yeah so these are Kuru Footwear and
this is the flux the atom the Rome and
the stride so basically the flux and the
atom are kind of my go-to like what you
have right here for our athletic people
like you like to walk at night I see you
and your husband I don't see as many
videos anymore but you and your husband
love to do that and they've got a
patented Kuru like exclusive technology
to their soul so it's really about
people that have fatigue in their feet
this has got a lot of heel and arch
support built in that it's really going
to just cup the back of your ankle
really really grip the other ones that
the stride in the room are all about
kind of people just casually walking
here in Vegas throughout this stuff I
love their colors they're great for men
obviously for women and when you put
them on I seriously I joke that I could
be in a Fred Flintstone cartoon I have
short why wide feet I'm always really
uncomfortable I have very high arches so
these are really going to support those
people with high arches and again that
have the foot fatigue I love the cushion
in them those are great oh yeah we have
one minute left I want to get to this
yes so this is what does it say it's
getnova.com so if you have allergies you
have anything that is happening with
your nasal passages obviously right now
we're all about the fact that everyone
still has viruses but if you have
allergies here in Las Vegas this is a
product that you want it's all natural
it was developed by a plastic surgeon
excuse me an ears nose and throat
surgeon he also does some plastic stuff
for over 25 years in California he
developed this is all natural three
times you can use it a day it's
non-addictive your kids can use it you
can use it it's my absolute go-to at
this point in time it's going to take
care of that inflammation or allergies
and again going to any of the pool
parties right now your kids are back at
school soccer practice
and then lastly we've got ub.com and
again this is at Target these again are
basically for the kids that you kind of
already back into the classroom and you
want to know what everybody else is
having you can just run on over to
Target so they've been around since 2014
they're all about the buy one give one
they've donated over to 6 million kids
as of right now they've got the great
Marvel collection with Spider-Man member
Spiderman Spiderman they've got
everything and I just love that they
give back so when you're buying these
products you know that you're buying
something good for your kids and other
kids as well they're like 2.99 to 20 for
them cute erasers really cute water
bottles they have something for everyone
look at these cute pencils for the
soccer I love that I'm taking this
pencil case you always bring us the good
stuff done thank you so much if anyone
wants more information on any of these
products you could go to dawnscorner.com
thank you for joining us